1967 le mathématicien andré li chn 08
président à une commission pour mettre à
jour les programmes scolaires français
en mathématiques
ce fut la mise en place de la réforme
des mathématiques modernes
une réforme qui allait grandement
changer la france et sa relation ambiguë
avec les mathématiques
cette réforme était inspiré presque
exclusivement par les travaux de l'un
des mathématiciens les plus productifs
de l'histoire le grand le géant
légendaire nicolas pour pâques est né au
pôle de vie à la fin du dix neuvième
siècle
nicolas bourbaki fut effaré par
l'émiettement des mathématiques et le
manque de rigueur de ses contemporains à
l'instar de p and o russell et gaudeul
pour ba qui souhaite imposer des
fondements unique inébranlable pour tout
les mathématiques son outil de
prédilection pour ce faire était un haut
niveau d'abstraction encore jamais
atteint dans l'histoire des
mathématiques ce qu'il suffirait de
cette abstraction fut l'oeuvre de sa vie
en 1939 nicolas bourbaki réutiliser
fondement axiomatique d'ermelo et
d'abraham fraenkel ainsi que l'action du
choix dans son appareil dans l'épisode
15 et publie le premier volume des
éléments de mathématiques comme le titre
l'indiqué cet ouvrage et élémentaires se
veut dire qu'il fascine ça veut dire
qu'il peut se lire sans aucun pré requis
ceci étant dit je vous conseille pas
forcément de le lire même si il n'y a
pas de prérequis à la lecture de ce
bouquin vaut mieux être assez à l'aise
avec l'abstraction mathématique
bref ce qui est vraiment incroyable
c'est qu'en partant de la théorie des
ensembles 2 rbds et l'eau et fraenkel et
de l'action du choix nicolas bourbaki a
réussi à écrire toutes les mathématiques
dans le langage uniquement de cette
théorie des ensembles c'est à dire cette
théorie qui ne peut manipuler
techniquement que des symboles de la
logique le signe égal est le signe
appartient à sachant que les
mathématiques de bourbaki sont devenus
les mathématiques standard ça veut dire
que d'un point de vue standard en
mathématiques il n'ya en fait que des
ensembles de la théorie des ensembles
des airs mélo et fraenkel tous les
objets mathématiques les courbes les
points et les nombres douceur ce n'est
qu'une histoire ensemble et j'y
reviendrai dans un épisode hardcore
typiquement le nombre entier n + 1
s'obtient en construisant un nouvel
ensemble à partir de lantier haine qui
lui-même est aussi un ensemble plus
étrange encore le nombre négatif -1 peut
être défini comme un ensemble infini qui
contient toutes les paires dentier
naturel n aime tel que m est égal à
haisnes plus un canton nombre racine
carrée de 2 il est souvent défini lui
comme étant l'ensemble de toutes les
paires dentier relatif paix et qu tels
que pkr est est plus petit que deux fois
qu carrés près les détails importe peu
ce que je veux vraiment vous montrer
c'est que dans la théorie 2 rbds et
l'eau fraenkel et maintenant nicolas
bourbaki la théorie que l'on appelle la
daf s'est tous les objets mathématiques
sont des ensembles assez étrange
et si certains de ces ensembles mérite
le titre de nombre c'est en vertu de la
situation de poincaré qui disait que les
mathématiques sont l'art de donner le
même nom à des choses différentes on
reviendra sur ce principe fondamental
des mathématiques dans un prochain
épisode
mais en particulier si on a des
ensembles qui se comportent comme des
nombres et bien les mathématiciens
s'autorise à appeler ces ensembles
dénombre oui je sais c'est super bizarre
plus bizarre encore et la manière dont
la théorie zdf s'est défini des
opérations comme l'addition
souvenez-vous dans l'arithmétique de p
and o on avait le droit d'écrire un
poussin est égal à 2 en gros puisqu'on
avait le droit de parler de l'addition
plus et du symbole égal mais dans cet
axe et on n'a pas le droit aux symboles
plus a priori non seulement le symbole
plus est interdit dans le langage de lfc
mais en plus le symbole égale lui a un
sens un petit peu différent puisqu'il
s'agit d'une égalité entre on semble a
priori typiquement dans un fc le symbole
égal et intimement reliés aux symboles
appartient à à travers l'axiome
d'extension nalité qui dit que deux
ensembles sont égaux si et seulement si
tout objet de l'un est un
de l'autre bref provenant un l'addition
comme vous l'avez deviné comme tout
objet dans un fc est un ensemble
l'astuce pour définir l'addition dans un
dlc est d'introduire un nouvel ensemble
qui va décrire cette addition et qu'on
va appeler à dd intuitivement l'ensemble
had va contenir l'ensemble des triplets
de nombre x y et z tels que x ou y est
égal à z et de la même façon on peut
définir l'ensemble mult des triplets de
nombre x y z tels que x x y est égal à z
et ça ça veut dire que toute formule
logique que je peux écrire dans le
langage de l'arithmétique de p and o
peut être traduite en une relation en
soliste entre des objets de la théorie à
des fc ont particulier avec les mêmes
raisonnements que ce qu'on a sorti dans
l'épisode précédent
on peut écrire une preuve du théorème de
gödel pour la théorie
z c'est bref depuis les travaux de
bourbaki tout tout tout dans les
mathématiques standard est une histoire
de relations entre des ensembles et ça
ça veut dire que les vrais objets
d'étude des mathématiques standard
requiert un niveau d'abstraction
monstrueux qui nous éloigne des
applications concrètes
cette abstraction extrême et déroutante
mais elle est aussi incroyablement
puissante elle est même indispensable
pour aller plus vite plus loin dans la
compréhension des mathématiques et
résoudre une multitude de problèmes avec
un minimum d'effort cependant cette
abstraction extrême a posé de gros
problèmes pédagogiques voire des
troubles psychologiques pour des
générations d'écoliers
la réforme des mathématiques modernes de
l'isch noro 8 a conduit à l'enseignement
de la base 2 et de la théorie des
ensembles naïveté l'école primaire
les collégiens eux apprenait ensuite les
relations les applications sous l'angle
de la théorie des ensembles glissé
ensuite des jeunes adolescents se
mettaient à la théorie des groupes des
corps et à l'algèbre linéaire avec le
formalisme des quantifie catr
l'abstraction extrême des mathématiques
à la française a encore aujourd'hui des
conséquences sur la compétitivité de la
recherche française en mathématiques
un jour alors que j'étais chercheur aux
états unis où on claque de bureau qui
était iranien me partager à son
admiration pour un étudiant en thèse
égyptien et là je répondis que en fait
cet étudiant égyptien a fait ses études
en france
mon collègue de bureau iranien s'est
exclamé à ça explique tout un niveau
bien plus élevé
les mathématiciens français sont les
seuls à encore défié l'hégémonie
américaine en nombre de médailles fields
cependant l inverse pour tous ceux qui
ont été larguées pendant les cours de
mathématiques et qui ont abandonné les
mathématiques à l'école
la réforme des mathématiques modernes de
l'isch numéro 8 est une catastrophe
la réforme de l'isf nero 8 c'était
abrupte et violente et l conduisirent
levée de boucliers chez les professeurs
les instituteurs et les parents d'élèves
non seulement les élèves étaient largués
mais leur encadrement l'était tout
autant
cette réforme de l'isf 0,8 à renforcer
le sentiment d'élitisme autour de la
maîtrise des mathématiques et à nourrir
un triste d amour pour les mathématiques
et il y aura beaucoup de choses à dire
sur les programmes scolaires en
thématique surtout avec les réformes
récentes et la baisse annoncée du niveau
des élèves en mathématiques mais bon je
laisse ça pour ma force est pour finir
cet épisode je vous propose de revenir
sur le légendaire nicolas bourbaki
avant de devenir un mathématicien de
tout premier rang bourbaki se lança dans
une carrière militaire qui le mena
jusqu'au titre de général des services
de renseignements pôle d'aig en 1928 il
rencontra von neumann plus kolmogorov ce
qui nourrit un intérêt soudain pour les
mathématiques
il n'anticipe a ainsi le second théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel dès 1930 mais ne
publiant pas ses idées
puis il se lança dans son ouvrage
éléments de mathématiques pendant la
guerre il rejoint les rangs de l'armée
soviétique et fut récompensé pour ses
nombreuses prouesses militaires au
lendemain de la guerre il découvrit par
lui-même la théorie de l'information de
shannon et à dori des jeux de nash à la
fin des années 1950
en parallèle des publications des
volumes de son oeuvre magistrale il a
réussi à prouver une partie de
l'hypothèse de riemann en montrant que
le nombre de zéros non triviaux de la
fonction état en dehors de la ligne
critique est fini il envoya sa preuve
alexandre krauth indique alors connu
comme étant le plus grands
mathématiciens du monde mais groth
indique perdit le manuscrit de bourbaki
en 1962 bourbaki partis au front à cuba
où il se fit capturé par les américains
il restera dans une prison américaine
jusqu'à la fin de sa vie où il a reçu
des visites régulières du grand
mathématicien andré weil andré veys
racontera plus tard que bourbaki sembla
avoir trouvé une preuve complète de
l'hypothèse de riemann mais que les
temps de visite autorisée était trop
étroit pour la contenir
vous l'avez compris les mathématiques
modernes de nicolas bourbaki si
difficile si abstraite et si obscur
demeuré néanmoins plus concrète que le
personnage même de nicolas bourbaki pour
back in
exister et oui j'ai inventé toute
l'histoire que je viens de vous raconter
pour ba qui n'était en fait que le nom
de plume d'un groupe secret de
mathématiciens essentiellement français
qui incluait notamment andré weil
jean pierre serre et alexandre
grothendieck de nos jours la flamme de
bourbaki c presque éteinte mais pas
complètement
le séminaire bourbaki reste l'un des
hauts lieux des mathématiques et y avoir
l'occasion de présenter ses travaux
reste l'une des plus prestigieuses
distinctions au sein de la communauté
mathématique
d'ailleurs fois on a parlé du théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel et vous avez
posé deux mini défilé dans l'épisode
donc le mini défilé 1 a été résolu par
jordan donc il s'agissait d'écrire mode
np est égal à air dans le langage de
l'arithmétique de p and o et ça
correspond à la division qui viennent
donc dire qu'il existe un coefficient au
cas tels que n est égale ap fois cas + r
et puis bon faut s'assurer aussi que le
reste r et bien entre 0 et paix - 1
il y avait aussi un mini défilé 2 qui
aller un peu plus loin et vous demander
de trouver une façon de parler des
formules de l'arithmétique de piano dans
le langage de l'arithmétique de p and o
c'est vraiment la première étape vers la
formalisation de la notion de proof qui
est vraiment la formule logique qui
était au coeur de toutes les
démonstrations de gödel et
malheureusement l'impression que je me
définis de est passée inaperçue sais pas
si quelqu'un il ya réfléchi en tout cas
eu malheureusement aucun commentaire à
ce sujet on m'a quand même donné la
solution la solution est elle est là et
vous voyez que dans cette solution il
faut notamment calculé paix puissance un
nombre et pour écrire ce ep puissance x
il faut utiliser ce dont on a parlé dans
la vidéo précédente c'est asus avec le
nombre entier avec qui on tient toutes
les étapes de calcul et j'espère qu'avec
cette formule vous commencez à avoir une
idée de comment est ce qu'on peut
continuer à manipuler des formules
logique de sorte
d'implémenter en fait les règles de la
logique et ensuite les axiomes de la
théorie pour pouvoir écrire la formule
prouve en entier la formule prouve en
entier à l est horriblement longue et je
doute même que quiconque sait déjà
écrite en entier pour l'arithmétique 2 p
and o du cac est généralement dans les
livres de cours nous donne les façons
d'écrire cette formule que les étapes
qui suivent ne jamais la formule entier
julien b nous demandent aussi la
démonstration que j'ai présentées dans
l'épisode précédent ne s'applique qu'à
l'art est multiple de piano et la
réponse est non comme on l'a vu en fait
toutes les astuces en fait pour parler
de la preuve un pôle pour formaliser
l'idée de preuves mathématiques dans le
langage de la théorie qu'on en train
d'utiliser si on est capable de traduire
toutes les formules logique de
l'arithmétique de pernod dans une autre
théorie alors cet autre théorie peut
également parler d'eux
la notion de prouve avec son propre
langage et du coup l'argument de google
s'applique à cette autre théorie c'est
en ce sens que vulgarisateur vous dis
souvent que le théorème de gödel
s'applique à toute généralisation de
l'arithmétique 2 p and o et comme toute
théorie mathématique après et contient
des nombres entiers
le théorème de gödel s'applique à toute
théorie mathématique mais c'est un petit
peu un abus de langage puisque la
victorine mathématiques ils seront pas
capables de formaliser tout la preuve de
gueule et on en parlera dans un prochain
épisode melgven biam on nous demande si
le deuxième théorème d'incomplétude de
gödel s'applique au premier tome
d'incomplétude de goodell le second
théorème d'incomplétude de gaulle disait
en gros que les mathématiques n'avait
pas de preuve de cohérence
cependant la preuve de ce théorème est
la preuve du premier tome d'incomplétude
de gödel ne nécessite pas tous les
outils de l'arithmétique de piano en
fait il ya nécessite que des outils très
restreint très algorithmique
en fait ça ce que c'est de la
manipulation de symboles et d'ailleurs
c'est un petit peu pour ça que suite aux
travaux de gödel lui tous les travaux de
churchill turing qui ont permis de
mettre les fondements de l'informatique
et de cette manipulation algorithmique
en un nombre fini d'étape qui permet de
transformer une forme de logique en une
autre comme tout ce travail
algorithmique et très fini il les
chapeaux théorème de gödel qui
s'applique souvent des théories qui
contiennent au moins une infinité
d'objets qui doivent contenir pendant
tous les anti naturel et donc non le
second théorème d'incomplétude de google
ne s'applique pas aux premiers fans fred
pose la question du coût 6 en
mathématiques
on ne pourra jamais être sûr de quoi que
ce soit quel est l'intérêt de faire des
mathématiques
il ya deux réponses à la première c'est
que
si techniquement on est pas sûr à 100%
que les mathématiques et on ne pourra
jamais être sûr à 100% que la théorie
zad c est incohérente ça ne nous empêche
pas de nous comporter un peu comme des
scientifiques pour le coup n'a jamais
réussi à falsifier à des fc et fc fassi
fiable en ce sens où on pourrait
peut-être prouver un joueur que adf ces
fosses comme ça n'a jamais été le cas
jusque là on a tendance à penser que cet
accès est consistante donc bon du
mathématicien ont pas mal confiance en
les mathématiques et personnellement
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
plus confiance en réserve c'est en la
consistance des élèves c'est que dans
n'importe quelle théorie de physiciens
la deuxième réponse que je pourrais
donner à fred c'est que si on doute de
la cohérence des mathématiques standards
du k-7 de bombay qu'ils étaient ses ou
l'arithmétique de paix à nous mêmes on
peut vouloir se restreindre à des trucs
un peu plus finis ou plus tangible et
pour lequel il ya moins de doutes sur la
cohérence c'est le cas dans une certaine
mesure de l'étude des machine de turing
qui en un certain sens sont plus
crédibles mois sujette à des choses
bizarres que toutes les théories
mathématiques qui est isaksson choix par
victor santé une demande s'il est
possible étant donné un théorème
mathématique de prouver qu'il est
indécidable qu'il n'a pas de preuve
ben oui et des arts c'est arrivé à
plusieurs reprises dans l'histoire des
mathématiques et à chaque fois ça si tu
peux fait tout le monde dont on a déjà
parlé d'ailleurs dans l'épisode 14 du
théorème de greenstein qui est
indécidable dans l'arithmétique de
pernod et puis ya d'autres exemples on a
mentionné rapidement dans l'épisode 15
l'indécidabilité de l'hypothèse du
continu et puis un autre exemple
classique
les cardinaux inaccessible d'ailleurs
des cardinaux tellement grand qu'on ne
peut pas d obtenir en la piquant
l'opérateur de l'ensemble des partis le
pde x 12 appareils dans l'épisode 16 on
pourra jamais atteindre les cardinaux
inaccessible en appliquant paix et de
haine p2p de npd p2p 2ème destination
donc ça c'est sont typiquement des
exemples de théorèmes indécidable
supposer qu'ils sont faux ça donne un
lieu en fait à deux mâts thématiques
différentes
alain delannoy nuit nous demande comment
on peut prouver qu un théorème est
indécidable justement qu'il n'y a pas de
preuve
j'ai pas de recette magique et je pense
que justement il n'y a pas de recette
magique puisque priori on peut pas
exclure que l'indécidabilité d'un
théorème soit lui-même dessiné c'est à
dire qu'a priori on pourrait être
possible qu'on ne puisse pas prouvé
qu'il n'y a pas de preuves ce qui est
assez tordu enfin vincent nous dit que
ma conclusion de la vidéo précédente
c'est qu'il existe des théorèmes
mathématiques qui sont vraies qui n'ont
pas de preuve avec l'exemple très
constructif d'ailleurs de qui a été
fourni par google mais du coup j'ai
prouvé que le théorème est vrai et qui
n'a pas de preuve
est ce que ça veut pas dire que j'ai
tout simplement prouvé le théorème vu
que j'ai quand même fini par déduire
qu'il était vrai alors oui j'ai prouvé
le théorème est en fait je l'ait pas
prouvé dans la théorie je l'éprouvé dans
une théorie extérieur le théorème de
gödel est un méta t om c'est à dire
qu'il n'appartient pas à la théorie
mathématique dont il parle
une façon d'interpréter de terminaux
google qui lui donne beaucoup moins de
charme et de mystère c'est de dire qui
et c'est juste en fait une étude du
langage d'une théorie et des règles pour
passer d'une phrase une autre phrase
donc c'est juste un jeu sur le langage
que la théorie mathématique et des
règles qui permettent de passer d'où une
phrase à une autre et du coup les
éléments nécessaires à la preuve de
gödel c'est vraiment juste des
manipulations donc encore une fois c'est
très algorithmique et en particulier ça
ne nécessite pas tout l'air tout
l'arsenal de l'arithmétique de p and o
ou autre puis je vous renvoie vers
l'épisode de 17 sur les paradoxes de la
logique mathématique on a pas mal
exploré cette petite différence entre
résonner à l'intérieur d'une théorie et
raisonné à l'extérieur d'une théorie
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
la prochaine fois il va y avoir un
épisode hardcore du coup sûr commandant
et d'accès ont construit
nombre notamment et puis il va avoir les
vacances de noël donc à y avoir un petit
peu entre eux sur scène ce soir à lui
dans les prochaines semaines mais
j'espère bien vous revoir à la rentrée
où on va parler notamment de théories
mathématiques alternative
et oui ça existe et on peut d'ailleurs
être sûr dans certaines de ces théories
mathématiques que le terme de me guédel
ne s'applique pas que du coup tout
théorème de cette mathématique à une
preuve même des profs de consistance de
ces théories j'espère que ça va éclairer
certains points par rapport au théorème
d'incomplétude de gödel si vous avez
aimez cette vidéo pensez à le lire et à
le commenter à le partager pensez à vous
abonner pourrait manquer les futurs
épisodes merci au deep purple en dons et
j'espère que je verrai à la rentrée pour
qui c'est une partie extrêmement
importante de l'histoire des
mathématiques
remember me